et voici olivier de kersauson
olivier le cap selon madame messieurs on
se marre bien et vous très bien voilà
notre ami remplace linda hardy désormais
auprès de moi dans les émissions comment
tu le trouves jeu court mais je parle
pas intellectuellement bien sûr bon
alors on y va olivier donc dernier week
end cette semaine donc du salon nautique
international de paris
mille deux cents bateaux cent mille
mètres carrés trois cent mille visiteurs
on peut dire que désormais la mer est
devenue une passion française c'est
tabarly qui a fait découvrir la faune à
la voile aux français en 64 et donc ça
fait plus de 320 f à 40 cents maintenant
et je pense que ça a été
en france un engouement formidable il ya
qu'à voir le succès des des
manifestations consacrées aux vieux
gréements le succès l'émission thalassa
sur france 3 le vendredi soir pour 7,1
soit les français sont vraiment accro à
la mer maintenant puis comme c'est un
petit domaine un peu de liberté encore
c'est un petit domaine dans lequel il
n'y a pas trop d'interventions de de
réglementation il ya une vraie liberté
cette dernière ailleurs quoi alors c'est
vrai formule le dernier ailleurs c'est
pas mal et encore une autre
comme ça la grosse dame et je te regarde
quelques si tu veux alors toi de cette
mer tué le héros
m
alors sombrero aussi les participants de
la route du rhum c'est michel desjoyeaux
qui a qu'à gagner mais la première à
pointe à pitre c'était une fille c'est
ellen macarthur ouais ouais
cet acier sa non non ça ne va pas tu
peux faire je pense que le si on devoir
porter les choses à valeur égale je
pense que la victoire de florence
arthaud il ya dix ans était beaucoup
plus maritime mans brillante que celle
de les délais de macarthur sur l'oréal
coq sur cette course là vous dire un
truc aussi c'est ken mac arthur c'est
bien la duplicité féminine était partie
en jouant même nom mais ça c'est
l'orgueil les organisateurs parce que ce
métier en train de glisser dans les
mains de damas et autres organisateurs
qui font qu'ils sont plus des
organisateurs que dd jean lemay en
herald hors série noire dans cette route
du rhum c'est c'est incroyable et les
chiffres
lionel 19 à l'arrivée sur 68 c'est ça
une des conditions météo tout à fait
exceptionnel et qu'aucun métérologue à
la au départ de la route du rhum il y
avait quand même la fine fleur de la
météorologie française et européenne
et personne n'avait prévu que cette
dépression qui devait avoir 40 noeuds de
vent ce qui doit faire 70 km heure on en
rêve jusqu'à 180 kilomètres donc le tout
le monde était surpris par
l'extraordinaire violence de la mer et
du système météorologique ponctuelle à
ce moment là ce qui fait que c'est un
mélange d'air chaud et l'air froid mais
une sorte de mini tornade pas très large
à peu près 350 km de large à l'intérieur
de cette tornade fallait pas aller du
tout oui mais pas du tout il fallait pas
donner le départ alors à non ça c'est
autre chose donner le départ en course
et la responsabilité de du capitaine
c'est lui qui décide si part ou pas il
n'y a que le nom le départ doit être
donné
c'est une des belles règles de ce sport
c'est qu'on donne le départ
personne n'est obligé de le prendre et
c'est c'est le premier acte de décision
de capitaine que fait l'individu quand
ils coupent la ligne oui la coupe a fait
ce qu'il fallait faire alors c'était
descendre éviter la sortie fallait
rester dans l'ouest avait pas descendre
vers le sud
ils sont tous plantés les mecs alors pas
tous mais beaucoup et beaucoup avec une
casse avec des chavirage et chavire h
est souvent une erreur de conduite
mais ma chance de conduite les mais la
rupture des bateaux
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de dégâts mais
il quand même beaucoup de casse avait
commencé avec vous cet hiver quand vous
êtes parti sur jéronimos été obligés de
faire demi-tour avarie de safran mais on
casse parce que je pense qu'ils ont fait
les bateaux qui ont jamais été fait il
n'y a jamais eu avant gironimo un
trimaran de cette année donc faire du
russe c'est vrai qu'on a des budgets
réellement n'a pas des budgets l'étude
lorsque renault fait une voiture il va
dépenser 6 6 à 7 millions d'euros pour
étudier la nouvelle roue alors que nous
chaque bateau est une éprouvette
c'est vrai qu'on perd aussi les grosses
séquences de l'éprouvette on n'a pas
toujours les moyens de nos ambitions on
en a certains qu'on les a pas tous ses
cd test en réalité c'est testant oui le
bateau est une éprouvette donc ya pas de
y'a pas loin il n ya pas de secours
alors la tempête n'a pas été pour rien
non plus dans la marée noire du prestige
pétroliers à simple coque donc comme on
l'a appris depuis qui avait 26 ans et
maintenant 77 mille tonnes de brut vont
s'écrouler dans la mer au rythme de 125
tonnes par jour énorme catastrophe
écologique
d'autant plus que ce pétrole une
remontée à la surface est de pouvoir
être ratisser d'une certaine façon ils
restent en boule au fond de la mer ni
atout yannick bien qu'on a on a il ya
des effets thermiques ou ça remonte
parfois salaire de heureusement balcon
la température baisse et puis il y a
oui c'est un fait l'expression ni amer
des nations exact pour pour ce qui se
passe est là pour des années là pas mal
de temps sur mon passé c'est plus grave
que l'exxon valdez le torrey canyon
c'est pas le même produit pour relier en
rien la pression que moi j'ai vu des
échantillons ce pétrole à brest n'a aux
cèdres et on a l'impression que c'est un
résidu de cracking c'est à dire c'est un
c'est cesser le sait déjà le pétrole
dénaturer le pétrole en soi est presque
organique
ouais mais là cette digne se déchaînent
pétrole est vraiment d'une grande
toxicité d'une cité de sevran c'est une
saloperie pure et simple mais en plus ça
émulsifié avec l'os dire que vous prenez
une tonne de ce pétrole vous le mettez
deux comme c'est le cas à être brassée
dans l'eau de mer
il va prendre 62 % d'eau qui est que
s'il va pas falloir nettoyer une tonne
de sa main il faudrait tout nettoyer
trois tonnes de favori sans compter le
conglomérat qui se fait quand ça arrive
sur la cause de ça se mélange avec
algues et autres déchets marins donc on
va arriver à 470 mille tonnes de pétrole
qui flotte et sur ces 70 mille tonnes de
pétrole il va falloir nettoyer 210 mille
tonnes de l'échec de son 210 mille
tonnes ça fait 210 km à une tonne par m
ouais et ça c'est effrayant mais n'a pas
attendu cette masse tue tous n'y a pas
que ça parce que la marée noire c'est un
petit peu la partie visible de l'iceberg
est un gros problème aussi c'est le cil
dégazage il ya vingt-six dégazage par
mois en france
non mais on voit bien l'homme transport
de plus en plus de matières qui sont
nuisibles bonne pour son économie bonne
pour notre santé parfois bonne pour nos
activités mais qui sont nuisibles et sur
le pétrole
l'histoire du pétroliers à double coque
c'est c'est un souhait c'est un voeu
pieux parce que là pétroliers à double
coque ça va casser comme un pétrolier a
simplement et en plus quand il s'agit de
déchets crack in good raffinerie ce qui
a l'air d'être le cas sur le le dernier
naufrage celui du
du prestige quand vous avez des déchets
vous n'avez pas envie de les mettre dans
les bateaux neufs parce que les bateaux
neufs transportera un produit plus noble
but donc avec un bios il faut six ans
portait un quelque chose qui est très
frappant c'est que on a eu beaucoup de
marée noire on n'a pas encore la culture
de manoirs ce que veut dire c'est que
les pompiers lorsqu'ils lorsqu'il ya un
incident sans carotte de faire la part
du feu
inquiet qu'on va battre un immeuble on
va sacrifier un morceau de quartier pour
sauver le reste de la ville là on sait
pas faire la part du feu c'est que moi
j'étais à vigo le pétrolier était à 4
milles de la côte
ouais 7 km la fuite était pas très
grande et à ce moment là les autorités
espagnoles ont refusé de le faire entrer
dans une baie c'est vrai que faire
entrer dans une baisse était pourrir la
b1 pour un certain temps mais que l'abbé
que la veille et surtout ça permettrait
peut-être de pompey marquis directement
on s'est mis à l'abri du vent à l'abri
de la mer était forte
parce que les vents avaient été très
violents et à ce moment là on aurait
peut-être pu récupérer les poumons s'y
opposer et les armateurs grecs sur
lequel tout le monde crie aujourd'hui et
pas plus ou moins juste titre en une
formule très étonnant aujourd'hui on se
trompe
le autrefois le bateau en avarie avait
droit aux secours dans le port est là et
on y lit une psychose intel bien un tel
malaise et une telle méconnaissance de
la marée noire dont le seul mot fait
trembler tout le monde
la possible la réalité de la marée noire
qui à l'époque était et est déjà
mauvaise mais pas très grave le
pétrolier se contentait de fuir
donc on pouvait récupérer et puis cette
réaction moyenâgeuse de dire on éloigne
des côtes mais on éloigne des côtes dans
un pays où le vent vous ramène tout à
l'alcool donc c'est d'une incohérence
totale si on est loin des causes en
remorque un bateau blessés j'ai jamais
vu une fêlure sari par elle-même la
fêlure ne peut qu avec du mouvement de
mer s'agrandir donc amené la casser
l'épanchement du pétrole oui c'est
exactement comme mettre les cendres sous
le tapis au lieu de balayer la même
théorie votre formule et là ça me
rassure tu n'as plus que je vois
quelques fois je vous ai bien expliqué
alors pourquoi il n'y a pas la même
rigueur sur merck dans les airs parce
que même les avions c'est hyper
surveiller il ya des couloirs aériens il
ya des contrôleurs du ciel choisir
salaire assez organisés pourquoi la sur
mer alors évidemment on commet disais
tout à l'heure c'est le dernier ailleurs
certes enfin pour des bateaux qui font
du commerce
ils vont pas pour s'évader les mecs
n'ont d'abord parce que il ya quand même
il ya plus d'avions qui tente par an que
de que deux pétroliers qui coule
ouais le milieu aérien et est soumis à
des règles très strictes parce qu'il ya
du transport de passagers
vu que s'il ya un simple il ya certain
laxisme dire que un jour enfin je le
séjour est arrivé aujourd'hui il va
falloir comprendre qu'on ne veut pas
transporter des matières dangereuses
écologiquement parlant n'importe comment
ça c'est une réalité dans l'histoire des
marées noires
exxon valdez alba doivent et trois ans
une amoco cadiz le vaudois avait 4 ans
ne s'était pas eu des bateaux poubelles
c'est pourquoi mais il y avait aussi
l'erreur humaine la mauvaise décision
pas prises au bon moment ce que le ski
est apte la question qu'on peut se poser
c'est est ce que dans nos systèmes
démocratiques formidable d'ailleurs on
arrive à avoir tout à coup une brutalité
de la brutalité de décisions nécessaires
devant une période de crise très courte
dans lequel on devrait passer un
autoritarisme extraordinaire et très
violent 1
il utilise est préférable de faire
entrer ce bateau ne fût ce que par la
force dans une guérilla
l'espagnol qui aura été pour humer la
seule réelle cela va arrêter pour y
prétendre il faut que quelqu'un décide
une décision terrible oui et une
décision terrible qui va le rendre
impopulaire à 501 et sa personne n'a
voulu les élus là bas je dis non surtout
pas avec tous les corps la mecque est
d'accord c'est sarkozy lui si on lui
donnait la mer en plus de la terre et
seraient ravis et mais il veut régner
l'ordre
moi je sis il fallait sarkozy sur la mer
pourvu qu'ils aient de magoar moi je
prends sarkozy tout c'est bien sûr aller
soit une seconde puis la trouvez comment
à la télé le jeu
j'ai pas regardé ce que j'étais ce qui
au chantier à l'époque c'était pas mal
ils étaient entre entre deux chavannée
bonaparte tu vas pour donner pour donner
un exemple de l'émission mathieu au
moins ça peut-être mais au moins
maintenant on peut pas dire qu'on n'a
pas de ministre de l'intérieur mais
également on pouvait se demander alors
qu'olivier c'est sérieux pourquoi ne
prenez-vous pas la tête d'une
association de défense de la mer voilà
contre les pétroliers trop vieux contre
les capitaines de pétroliers trop con
contre le dégazage n'importe où pourquoi
ne le feriez vous pas puisque vous êtes
l'homme de la mer en france
pourquoi je fais pas ça parce que moi
parce que je dois être assez lucide sans
doute et je crois pas beaucoup dans le
blabla c'est pas du ténor vingtaine
d'obligés pas il faut pas faire une
association faut faire une règle
ouais c'est à dire vous passez par point
final bien que on prend la liste les
bateaux existants dans le monde existe
ya des registres tel ou tel hôtel tell
tale tel bateau vous ne franchissait pas
telle latitude
oui voilà c'est tout mais ça peut créer
une loi pour ça ah oui là justement
faire faute est là qu on s'embrouille
l'audio il y avait il y avait une
commission européenne charmante au
demeurant pas stupide de plus qui
expliquait qu'elle allait faire des lois
mais comme les lois tout le monde s'en
fout elle sont jamais respectées elles
ne sont pas respectées
80% des lois sont pas mais vous rigolez
donc une loi une loi non faut dire voilà
nous français espagnol on a décidé que
cette piste-là ne pénètre pas au ghana
et côte
si jamais espoir on envoie nos bateaux
de guerre et aux captures tout le monde
et on les met en prison voilà là on aura
peut-être des choses différentes mais
avant si on refait un port du texte de
loi
si vous avez dans notre monde notre
europe essentiellement juridique long
pont du papier des lois tous les tous
les quarts d'heure un moment donné il
faut se porter aux réalités je sais pas
au bord de la plage avec votre texte de
loi bondi vers la marée noire
il ya une autre solution c'est que vous
veni un corsaire c'est à dire au service
de la france avec un bateau avec des
petits canons tout autour du bassin
saint jean mais non mais le pétrolier
est un chanteur formidable vous voulez
tirer dessus ou face à nice et vannes
que vous craignez ouais non mais je
pense que c'est dans l'anticipation
c'est vraiment prendre la décision de ne
pas faire circuler ces produits
n'importe quand et n'importe comment
avec des produits ça demande une plus
haute surveillance que c'est le cas
actuellement
il faudrait peut-être avoir un corps de
garde côtes mais ça parce que nous on a
à se mêler de la main on à la
gendarmerie la douane la marine
nationale
les hospitaliers sauveteurs bretons
devenus snsm aujourd'hui on n'achète pas
combien de corps dont il n'y a pas de
diète personne qui dit on fait ça on
fait pas ça alors pourquoi pas des
garde-côtes
parce que la douane ne veut pas
abandonner ses privilèges maritime que
la gendarmerie ne veut pas abandonner
ses prix village maritime que personne
ne veut puis un corps de garde paul
c'est aussi une culture est en fête
à la décharge de nos institutions on n'a
pas de culture demain on en a eu deux
effets catastrophiques 3 presque avec le
thallium on n'a pas de culture de marée
noire je pense quelque ans elle commence
à être fait et à ce moment là je pense
qu'on gérera mieux mais tout est très
lent l'ennui c'est que c'est très
spectaculaire très dévastateur est très
nuisible qui est que le coût réel d'une
marée noire est beaucoup plus cher que
le coût que pourrait nous faire le monde
entier en procès parce qu'on a dévié un
bateau en les menaçant
c'est non seulement c'est la ville se
trompent économiquement
intellectuellement et écologiquement de
discours tels que je pense qu'à un
moment donné il faudrait passer une
certaine forme de brutalité
nous devons faire comprendre que on n'en
veut pas le consensus est trop lent 1
or la plupart de nos élus le bord de mer
connaissent rien du tout tant qu'on
n'aura pas le ministre de la marine
aujourd'hui c'est un mec qui viennent là
du bord de mer non
je sais pas non à un ministre de
l'agriculture d'un abri d'accord et de
la pêche aya pas ministres avant les
valises de la mer avant nous étions une
nation maritime en en 40 ans on a perdu
les trois quarts de nos basses eaux
l'ensemble d'ailleurs c'est le cas de
tous les sociétés évoluées tir que le
transport maritime à cause de son coût
et tout court est de plus en plus non
c'est pas plus une affaire mais il est
de plus en plus déléguer aux pays
pauvres les pays pauvres les équipages
et que le moi j'ai vu des bateaux dans
lesquelles les équipages ne sait pas
aller à taire de peur de perdre leur job
et on se plaint beaucoup des pavillons
de complaisance parce qu'ils peuvent
engager sur leurs bateaux des philippins
où des gens pas cher et c'est enfin en
france aux kerguelen
on donne des autorisations qui sont
comparables à celles du liberia par
exemple oui mais faut pas oublier non
plus que le actuellement sur se sait pas
quel bateau de pour le ps français
l'ensemble de l'équipage et polonais
ouais les gens ne veulent plus aller
naviguer ce métier est trop dur large
ici leur dur labeur feuille blanche elle
ment parce que vous vous voulez de faire
votre rêve donc vous vous partez pour le
trophée jules verne à leur perron il a
mis combien de temps lui il à 1064 jours
ouais et vous voulez faire 60 qua non
enfin je veux faire mieux possible
c'est pas du tout parlé moi je suis ceux
qui préfèrent agir on en parlera après
on fera tout pour faire moins